so
okay what was the guy's name who owned
the house the who sold the trent
resonator
uh rudy altabelly rudy and he tell you
an interesting story about him that just
happened recently so quentin tarantino
released his movie you know a few months
after my book came out once upon a time
in hollywood
and i think it was his most successful
movie box office wise to date
and i had two mutual friends of his and
one of them is one of his producers and
his longtime first ad
and the other one was an ex-girlfriend
who's one of his only ex-girlfriends who
remained friends with him
so both of them gave him a copy of my
book an advanced copy that i had signed
months before my book came out and
months before his movie came out
and they both they said we're not going
to give it to him unless we read it
first
we know you we love you but we want to
make sure it's something that he'd like
because everybody wants you to give
something to quentin right
so they did and you know he never
read it and i i wasn't surprised because
um
he you know he's about to release one of
the biggest movies of his career
right a lot of publicity so uh about a
year after
like last fall i think it was i got a
call from one of our mutual friends and
he said can clinton call you now
i'm gonna go excuse nice i needed him
like two years ago but sure
i go why he goes he's obsessed with your
book
he finally got to read the one i gave
him
and he has a million questions and you
know if quentin tarantino has a million
questions that means it's like
so he called me from israel where he was
living and um
in israel well i just read an interview
with him a couple days ago uh
i knew he was there and i didn't know
why i knew he had married an israeli
woman and had a baby there
but he when the pandemic hit they
wouldn't let him back in
so he got i guess hopefully he's not
still there now
he was on jimmy kimmel a couple nights
ago okay but he was there during a lot
of that
and the interview i read said i think he
was in tel aviv
he didn't say anything about you know
bombings violence or anything he just
said how much he loved it there
yeah so he and his wife and kid have now
moved back i think in the last month or
two
but so he started calling me and it
wasn't just because he had a million
questions but it was because he was
doing the novelization
of the movie where he's adding
fleshing out characters adding scenes
and he'd always wanted to write a
paperback book
kind of like a pulpy paperback book so
that comes out tuesday
and um he talking about rudy altebelli
and like our second or third
conversation like
and rudy how did you ever get rudy to
talk to that's amazing he goes damn it
you know
i've got his character in the book i
didn't have him in the movie
but but i have to you know fake his name
you know or he goes or do you think if
you reached out to rudy and asked would
he take like a quarter million dollars
from me to let me use his name
in the book and not promise not to sue
me
quentin rudy's been dead for 10 years
kidding me you just saved me a quarter
million dollars
you know i'm still in debt hundreds of
thousands of dollars right and i'm like
rude
or quentin give it to me well i should
have said
give me the cash and i'll deliver it to
rooney
oh yeah you definitely should have done
that so the book comes out tuesday and
i'm hoping
you know the name of it it's the same
name as the it's the title of the movie
once upon a time in hollywood
yeah yeah so i think he's he was on
jimmy kimmel a night or two ago
and i was flying so i didn't see it but
i read the recap
of the interview but i'm hoping you know
for the in-depth interviews
you know if he was telling me the truth
he said oh my god he goes i thought i
knew this and i didn't know anything
about this character that character i'm
hoping he'll
mention the book because all the clinton
fans
then might be interested and get the
book right yes
but it's already you know it's going to
be a bestseller because it's a quentin
tarantino book it's the first one he's
ever written and he keeps saying
i didn't just turn the novel into a
script he goes it's like
a whole fresh take new characters much
more about the manson family the murders
all this stuff because there was
literally barely anything about me yeah
in the movie yeah
yeah he released a trailer the publisher
released a trailer last week
that he put together for the book so
it's like a two-minute trailer
and he has scenes in the trailer that
are in the book but
they were cut from the movie so there is
a scene
between met the manson character
at the house looking for terry melcher
and they don't show who he's talking to
but
in real life it would have been rudy
altabelly
um so the guy who owned the house he
went up there looking for him so well
i'll know a lot when the book comes out
tuesday i hope he gives me an
acknowledgement if i saved him a quarter
million dollars
oh right yeah he definitely just put
your name in there shut you out
somewhere
yeah [ __ ] quinton um
so rudy so when you talk to rudy i mean
that
what what was it about rudy that opened
what did he tell you that open pandora's
box for you
he it began very slowly he started
telling me
that he had suffered more than anybody
else
who was associated with the victims
sharon
and um calcium abigail you know they
were all his friends too
rome he lived in the house behind the
main house so
rudy owned this beautiful property at
the top of cielo drive
it was like a a french-designed country
house
one story with like beautiful views
everywhere there was a pool and then
there was a guest house
so he lived in the guest house bought
the house i think in the 40s
and he among the tenants who stayed
there were katherine hepburn
clark gable carrie grant and then
terry melcher who's the son of doris day
he was a music producer
he moved in there in 65 moved out in
january of 69 and they all rented from
rudy and rudy always stayed in the back
house because that's all he needed
but he only ran into people he thought
he'd party with he was a huge partier
yeah he was one of the first out gay
guys
in hollywood who flamboyant didn't care
what people thought
real character and when he
when roman and sharon moved in he and
sharon became very very close sharon
tate so they moved in in
february of 69 and then in march the two
of them went to europe
him to do script notes and fixing on the
day of the dolphin which he was going to
direct in london
and sharon went to make a devil movie
called the 13 chairs in italy
and then they came back sharon came back
in
july and rudy never came back
he went over with sharon he flew over
there he wasn't her manager it was just
her best friend so they flew together
and then he went off with an actress
named olivia hussey
who um was in romeo and juliet which was
this big sensational 1969 movie
so his relationship with roman and
sharon and terry melcher was really
important to what became
the line of inquiry i was doing did
people in hollywood have relationships
with manson that were concealed
by either hollywood the machine the
publicity machine or law enforcement
and rudy started kind of telling me yeah
so he'd get drunk i'd usually drive him
home and he'd always want me to come
into a shitty little apartment for one
more night cap
and that's when he'd start talking and
he had a few drinks and he goes you know
what terry went on he had a great career
produced all these bands he was still
alive then
romans never suffered for this he was
the only one who lost their house
lost their reputation because people
thought he had a relationship with the
family
you know even law enforcement they
eventually said he did a relationship
with the manson family that was another
reason for them to come up there
um he was just bitter and angry and he
said
if the truth ever came out about roman
and them
and terry and dennis wilson of the beach
boys and some other people
he goes nobody would believe it but it's
true and i could tell you
and so he ended up started telling me
how to prove
that the district attorney buliosi had
covered up
the much more involved relationship with
uh terry melcher for instance
and then government people who were
involved with with manson and
it's hard to say with if people haven't
read the book and i don't want to give
too much away because
part of the fun of the book is you think
it's gotten pretty crazy and it's
over and then like the next couple pages
is like no what
it's even crazier
i